hey this is presh talwalker
here we have a string of beads formed by
Circles of the same size the string
passes through the center of each circle
so we have 25 Circles of the same radius
r
shade the circles areas that are
enclosed or interior to the string in
blue and shade the circles areas that
are exterior are not enclosed by the
string in Orange
what is the orange area minus the blue
area equal to in terms of r
this is from a manga called QED and I
think Sparky from the Philippines for
the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
so in almost all of puzzles with the
question like this you'll find that the
two shaded areas are equal to each other
so their difference would be equal to
zero but that is not the case in this
puzzle and that's why it's one of the
most wonderful puzzles I've come across
so here's how we can solve it
we will first review the area of a
circular sector
let's say this circle has a radius of R
and a central angle of theta degrees
now the total area of the circle is pi r
squared so we just want the fraction of
the circle which will be the fraction of
the central angle
so the area of the circular sector will
be equal to pi r squared the area of the
total Circle multiplied by the fraction
of the circle which is Theta degrees
divided by 360 degrees
now let's consider that we have
endpoints and we can join them to form a
concave polygon
not every Point has to be a vertex of
the concave polygon but all the points
together form a concave polygon
let's consider the angles that are
formed between the edges of this concave
polygon and each of these endpoints
so we want the sum of all of these
angles so how can we do it
we will first triangulate the polygon so
from a central point we will form
triangles
so here we're going to form n triangles
now the sum of the angles we want will
be equal to the sum of all the angles in
these triangles
minus the sum of all these angles in the
center but all of these angles in the
center will of course sum up to be 360
degrees so we subtract out 360 degrees
now every triangle's three angles will
sum up to 180 degrees and we have n
triangles so the sum of all the angles
in these n triangles will be equal to n
multiplied by 180 degrees and we
subtract 360 degrees
so we'll use this formula in a second
so first we will note that the Blue Area
plus the orange area is equal to the
total area of the 25 circles
so what's the total area it will be
equal to pi r squared times n and in
this case n is equal to 25 but let's
just keep it General where we have n
so let's focus on the blue area now
let's say the central angle of this
first circle is Theta 1. so what's the
area of this circular sector
it'll be pi r squared multiplied by
Theta 1 divided by 360 degrees here let
Theta 1 be in degrees
now let Theta 2 in degrees be the
central angle of the second Circle so
this circular sector will have an area
of pi r squared multiplied by Theta 2
divided by 360 degrees
we can do this for all of these circles
so we'll add in all of these areas and
then let Theta n be the central angle of
the last Circle so we have pi r squared
multiplied by Theta n divided by 360
degrees
so the sum of all of these circular
sectors we can factor out pi r squared
divided by 360 degrees and we multiply
that by the sum of the central angles
Theta 1 to Theta n
but now we know what the sum of data 1
to Theta n is we know that the sum of
all of these n angles will be equal to n
multiplied by 180 degrees minus 360
degrees
we simplify this to get pi r squared
multiplied by n over 2 minus 1. and
that's the blue area
so now we know what the blue area is and
we recall that the total area is equal
to n multiplied by pi r squared so we
can calculate that the orange area is
the total area minus the blue area
and that will work out to be pi r
squared multiplied by n over 2 plus 1.
and we know that the blue area is equal
to pi r squared multiplied by n over 2
minus 1. so we can now take the
difference of the two areas
so what is the orange area minus the
blue area
the N over two terms will cancel out so
we are left with pi r squared multiplied
by two two pi r squared so the
difference of the orange and blue areas
is 2 pi r squared and amazingly the
difference is always the area of two
circles and this does not depend on the
number of circles it's an incredible
puzzle and a very unexpected answer
wow
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign